Democratic donors are showing Joe Biden
some love apparently his campaign says
he raised nearly forty seven million
dollars in March his best fundraising
month of the campaign actually more than
President Trump as he took control of
the Democratic Party the presumptive
Democratic nominee tweeted this in part
this virus has changed our campaign but
it has not changed the unwavering
support we've gotten from all of you
together we're going to defeat Trump
however Joe Biden and his political
party are nearly in total a hundred and
eighty seven million dollars behind the
RNC and the president who you may know
has spent the last three years
stockpiling his huge war chest and as
the New York Times points out Joe Biden
and the Democrats could raise a million
dollars a day between now and Election
Day and still barely catch up Steve
Hilton you've seen a campaign or two
across the pond how do you catch up when
you can't even get the the bully pulpit
anymore every day between 5:00 and 7:00
or so p.m. Eastern I can't get a word in
edgewise Joe Biden yeah and when he does
try to get a word in edgewise it's kind
of ends up being jumbled and incoherent
and not exactly what you want to hear in
the middle of such a serious situation
so I think even the performances that he
does manage to put on are exactly
reassuring seems to me there's a lot of
complacency building on the Democrat
side that Joe Biden is just going to
steam in their president trance made
such a mess of this crisis he's just
gonna obviously be defeated I think that
is completely wrong I think that
actually elections tend to be more about
the future than the past and the
arguments in November all line up in
favor of President Trump because
everything he's been saying for so long
on trade on bringing manufacturing home
as we saw early on immigration all these
things actually and on China let's
remember that big one there he's on the
right side president Trump's on the
right side of those big arguments Joe
Biden mister establishment mister Swamp
is on the wrong side of those arguments
and I think that's going to be decisive
in the general election you know Marie
harf in recent days we've been reading
more and more about the reporting that
former president
rock obama had a heavier hand if you
will behind-the-scenes when Bernie
Sanders were still in the race and and
kind of smoothing that whole thing out
and and now he's getting ready to help
he and the former first lady Michelle
Obama reportedly helped Joe Biden on the
campaign trail how much is that going to
make a difference well I can guarantee
you that Democrats are not complacent I
promised Steve that it may seem that way
to him but and the Democrats I talked to
it is anything but complacency and for
Joe Biden he had a trifecta of really
important endorsements in the last week
Barack Obama as you mentioned Harris
Bernie Sanders who endorsed by didn't
much earlier than he endorsed Hillary in
2016 and Elizabeth Warren who still has
a lot of support in many parts of the
party so Democrats are behind overall
and money but if money won election
Hillary Clinton would be President we
know it's not determinative and the
other important money numbers to look at
Harris are in the House and Senate races
House candidates on the Democratic side
are out raising their Republican
opponents by leaps and bounds
senator Senate candidates like Mark
Kelly doing the same thing Susan Collins
getting out raised right now up in Maine
by Sarah Gideon so Democrats are putting
their money to the presidency but also
to these House and Senate races to keep
the house and help flip the Senate
Democrats are fired up and their user ID
earlier than they were in 2016 Murray I
would just point this out though that
the playing field isn't exactly the same
when you talk about well if money had
been the answer then Hillary Clinton
could have won Hillary Clinton was not
going up against a pandemic and a
juggernaut of news conferences every day
between 5:00 and 7:00 p.m. by a
president whose numbers are pretty
steady throughout this whole thing we
talked about the pitches and the Falls
but there it's a pretty tight graph when
you look at them pictorially right so
the president's kind of holding steady
through this throughout this you're
gonna need some cash some cold hard cash
to get on the airwaves because the steve
has pointed out even getting a word in
edgewise is hard it's hard to do online
it doesn't quite compare here it's
interesting I think you and I have had
this conversation maybe last week on
outnumbered you are right the president
has a bully pulpit like no one else is
standing behind
whitehouse podium but at the same time
he is also saying a number of things
that are immediately ending up in Joe
Biden's attack ads because the president
likes to talk a lot and sometimes he
says things that aren't precise that
aren't entirely truthful like I don't
take any responsibility or I take no
responsibility so it's a little bit of a
double-edged sword that bully pulpit and
Joe Biden theory of the cases has always
been a return to normalcy and right now
he may be the establishment but he seems
stable and voters are looking for
stability right now I gotta tell you
when Steve says you know gosh all the
things that he is able to do at this
point Steve I want to give you a quick
last word because the future is now
every day late in the afternoon we get
to hear more and he's got more ink right
now as we say in journalism than than
the former vice president yes and I
think that although the the media and
the Democrats love to portray the worst
aspects of what comes out on a daily
basis I think what what more neutral
minded more independent and reasonable
people see there is a president who's
really taken charge of this who's on top
of the detail whether that's on
ventilators or PPE or whatever else you
know he's really taking charge and every
day they're seeing that and that's what
you want to see in a crisis and I think
that as we see potentially light at the
end of the tunnel on the medical crisis
as you see the real question turned to
who's going to help rebuild this country
after the economic and social disaster
of the shutdowns I think there's no
contest in terms of who has more
credibility with those those crucial
independent-minded voters about whose
best to do that and I think President
Trump's got all the arguments on his
side well you two will just have to
agree to disagree but it's it's
interesting to talk about